lors de jouera pas les questions au
gouvernement la parole est à monsieur
eric ciotti monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre
depuis plusieurs jours nous insistons un
déchaînement de violence inouïe dans
plusieurs villes de france
commissariats attaqués voitures
incendiées commerces pillés
notre pays plonge progressivement dans
le désordre
cette situation est intolérable elle est
insupportable
la ferté au doit être traitée dans la
sérénité par la justice et seulement par
la justice et conduire naturellement en
fonction des résultats de l' enquête aux
sanctions adaptées
mais rien ne peut légitimer la violence
rien ne justifie que l'on abandonne des
quartiers aux voyous depuis le début de
ces exactions
le gouvernement est absent pire par
votre comportement vous avez donné le
sentiment d'excuser l'inexcusable
monsieur le premier ministre les voyous
et les policiers ne peuvent pas être
mises sur le même plan
nous devons aujourd'hui rappeler que 26
policiers sont et gendarmes sont morts
en service l'année dernière nous devons
rappeler que seize mille policiers
gendarmes ont été blessés
nous devons leur dire notre
reconnaissance et notre confiance pour
le courage dont ils font preuve
face à une situation extrêmement
dangereuse que ce soit contre le
terrorisme où que ce soit contre la
délinquance monsieur le premier ministre
on ne dialogue pas avec les casseurs on
les combat nous vous demandons
aujourd'hui solennellement d'interdire
toute manifestation qui parle de
violences policières
nous vous demandons de déposer plaine
contre tous ceux qui diffament la police
oui ou non
entendez-vous rétablir l'ordre
républicain dans ces quartiers là où la
loi des casseurs s'est substituée aux
lois de la république
merci monsieur ciotti la parole est à
monsieur bruno le roux ministre
l'intérieur
oui monsieur le député ciotti je
voudrais d'abord excusé monsieur le
premier ministre qui est à berlin et qui
reviendra dans le courant de l'après
midi
vous parlez de la situation qui a été
générée par l'accident dans le tragique
accident dont a été victime le jeune
théo
je voudrais d'abord en appelant à la
sérénité et au calme dire et rappeler
que la justice est saisie et que rien ne
peut justifier la moindre exactions
aujourd'hui dans nos quartiers que la
justice passera le président de la
république l'a réaffirmé et que par là
même ceux qui mènent aujourd'hui des
campagnes de pillage des campagnes pour
brûler des poubelles des campagnes pour
pour attaquer les commissariats des
campagnes pour dégrader les biens seront
punis seront sanctionnés et sont d'ores
et déjà monsieur le député arrêté parce
que rien ne peut justifier leur
comportement
maintenant vous me permettrez peut-être
plus précisément de vous dire que la
police dans nos quartiers a été
particulièrement mise à mal ces dix
dernières années notamment par les
politiques que vous avez menées et je
veux vous le rappeler ici
il est beaucoup plus facile de dégrader
la sécurité de nos propres moyens il
vous connaît environ autant alors
accorder des vêtements nouveau je veux
donner ici un seul exemple en ce moment
ce sont quatre mille six cents élèves
qui sortent des écoles de police et qui
sont affectés en priorité en sécurité
publique
il y a cinq ans c'était 450 élèves qui
sortait des écoles et qui ne permet pas
qui ne permettait pas de répondre à la
moindre demande au sein des quartiers
donc monsieur le député vous vous y
connaissez particulièrement en émeutes
urbaines
vous en avez pendant plusieurs semaines
sans réussir à aucun moment à les
endiguer vous feriez mieux
las de ne pas vouloir donner de leçon
parce que le
vernement sera inflexible avec ceux qui
mènent la bataille au